[Musique]
cache cache cache cache cache
j'ai fait tomber mon talent vient te
ment heureusement la quotidienne aussi
bien protégé draps film à dire ah [ __ ]
mais c'est incroyable après les années
mais mec tu es incroyable
c'est fou il est huit heures du matin à
l'os et hacker géniale habituellement 8
heures du matin
mais ces dames c'est le jour qu'on
attendait depuis combien de temps ou
encore puisque nous n'était pas
l'adresse je ne crois même pas que c'est
vrai les amis c'est le moment tant
attendu sur ma chaîne youtube
c'est le moment de cache cache cette
vidéo a a été rendue possible grâce à un
petit partenariat qui justifie le fait
qu'on a envoyé tous nos téléphones par
terre au début de vidéo et v
tournée chromatique raynaud chinois
contact et ils m'ont dit on veut faire
cache-cache 2 c'est tombé comme ça du
ciel c'était incroyable jeune justin
mark de kok pour téléphones qui sont
extrêmement solide et de qualité
j'ai imaginé une marque de corte et
lucas économiste wa tout le monde
connaît rhinochill est ce que tout le
monde sait que j'ai sorti une collection
avec reno shield supporter cette
collection si je vous parle de ses
coffres
évidemment avec par exemple ce motif et
cette collection spéciale squeeze elle
elle est disponible
où et quand et comment elle est
disponible sur rhinochill point fr et
attention
deuxième bonne nouvelle avec le code
cache-cache voudra mais moins 10% mais
on va pas de faire le code cache cache
inventons le code aussi c'est le truc
avec rim film n'en fait ça tout le temps
au quai cale code dans l'institution
gencives jean source dit jean sèye de
coke est si vive le code cache-cache
c'est maintenant le code gencives
troisième et dernière bonne nouvelle
avant qu'on aille se cacher c'est en ce
moment le black friday sûr c'est très
moche est liée à -5 à -60% sur des tas
de coquilles compris celle de ma
collection ya aussi une collection nasa
via une collection naruto hunter x
hunter et une policière
et croyez-moi de ces coques sont très
solides comme en témoigne ce geste les
gars écoutez moi
raphaël est venu ici pour gagner
prendre du plaisir c'est non non
divertir c'est nous gagner dit oui au
cachette on les a travaillé pendant des
mois c'est la vidéo que j'attends le
plus dit vous juste qu'on a tout donné
pour vous plaire oui absolument
je rappelle les règles c'est essentiel
la première l'équipe qui cherche l'autre
équipe est lâchée en vannes 1 point à
elle connaît la position de l'autre
équipe grâce à la géolocalisation sur
votre téléphone
en arrivant sur les lieux vous avez 20
minutes pour trouver l'équipe adverse
vous n'avez pas le droit de rentrer dans
des lieux privés radio privée palu
intérieur que des espaces publics
attendez ce n'est pas dans des bâtiments
aie aie aie aie aie fait la ligue europa
dont les ventes dépassaient pas les
nerfs des ces messieurs dames
nous sommes maintenant prêts je n'ai que
la cache cache de ouvert ses portes
[Musique]
bon ticket qui attaque google
ils vont galérer et on sera en fait sous
le sol sous peu moi je suis content
qu'on va commencer la journée ils vont
être en colère se cacher ou et son
cachet ou des quoi leur première
cachette s'est pas privé les quatre si
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit fan des
bâtiments je pars bâtiment les gadins
cause c'est sous le sol moi je pense que
l'on a dit pas droit en intérieur et
qu'ils ont rappelé leur expliquer et un
truc là graf
il est dans un état incroyable peut que
gagner il sera tricheurs sur les règles
il l'était déjà dans l'ain oubliez pas
chez très mauvais joueurs donc ça s'est
passé beaucoup de choses aux ondes radio
[Musique]
les gars on est en train de rentrer dans
les carrières 10e peut être si le saut à
hu est quand même c'est giga lan
couloirs et les immenses max gloire
comme du thé
nous avons étudié apparemment ils n'ont
pas trop bougé et que nous faisons des
tours aux vans et beauxis qui nous
mijote [ __ ] est-ce qu'ils vont avoir
des clips tout de suite mais est ce
qu'ils vont pas l'avoir ils vont enrager
parce qu'il faut passer par un bâtiment
pour nous rejoindre c'est sûr il vaut
rejet de ouf tout c'est une image de
vraiment du futur ou yves roche vous
avez le droit de faire va vite nous en
commentaires moi en fait ça me stresse
parce que j'ai l'impression
il vous retrouvons trois secondes non je
viens d'avoir une vision jeu d'avoir un
flash hama sous un manteau dans un arbre
non mais ils sont à l'intérieur d'un
truc rappelle toi encore d'un cheval
c'est d'ailleurs une très bonne idée
petit ça c'est des morses
mais attendez du bad tour se voit que
c'est pas de la décrue
nous va être là en fait dodo trop drôle
secret arriver on sera là ils vont faire
ouais c'est un crawl on y va géologue
cela on est là de l'autre côté de la
place voilà la hausse approche on sabre
aux non c'est bon c'est bon vous êtes
squeeze sétois squeeze c'est l'apanage
de la crash-box ni riche ni la grille
quand même vous êtes là vous êtes
squeeze vous êtes la france je regarde m
d'angola et peuvent pas rentrer c'est
bien c'est impossible à s'ouvrir et
métal et ont pillé tue c'est impossible
a soulevé quoi c'est un bon indice
ok c'est bon j'aime que riba météo c'est
mon coeur qui bat qu'est ce que c'est ça
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que c'est
que ces dames c'est quoi il fit catag
aux catacombes d'années de laisser les
catacombes de paris attend en fait ils
sont en dessous vous les mecs juin
endorphines
là ils disent là juste là ne serait pas
la direction de l'autre côté ils sont là
dedans on n'a pas le droit d'y aller
c'est un intérieur attend ce que laisse
à bien voir bien avoir dans le 1
il était caché dans l'eau il y avait un
mec qui surveillait regardent ils ont
pas du tout l'air étonné de nous voir
ouais celle où je regarde regarde
regarde jouer lcq semer son côté regarde
jamais y aller et personne ne m'arrêtera
regardez à perth nous nous arrête mais
que c'est bon c'est bon de nos jours
dont jours c'est ouf c'est l'arrêt de
ouf
si c'est ça l'idée on va gagner mais
l'idée est géniale
par contre c'est que le sol est bien
olalala sens à sa vie durant ses
infinies ça se trouve c'est pas là du
tout oh my god les responsables top et
une rue entière
le dernier arrivé au ras des ongles à la
place de béton michael booth entre les
gars t'as trop moi pas du tout dans le
bon sens a pleuré des toits de rester
quatre minutes
par contre j'ai peur au nom va devoir se
séparer de ses parts attendent
maintenant je crois que c'est bon quoi
mais quoi mais la bavière
je descends tu envisages tu connais
oh [ __ ] ils font des blagues au moment
des 10 et son ex ces gens là bas des
gens on est dans le bon sens hahaha
yama cadreur ici c'est facebook compte
faut pas rigoler où ils nous ont amenés
[ __ ] c'est bien tard
il ya tellement de crabes et ou s'il
force la grille c'est la sela attends
attends ce qu'ils ont fait en mode jeu
vidéo ou alors c'est des comédiens non
choisie seule l'afrique pour qu'ils se
retrouvent de sanaa
on n'a pas le droit de faire ça
non
regardons ce égard aux coûts dégagées
pour nous avoir trouvé l'épave
c'était pas si simple en réalité on sait
quand même tendance à penser que c'est
un peu un intérieur
nous ne sommes pas dans un bâtiment
privé nous sommes sous le sol je veux
croire que ce matériau c'est fou de
croire que ce à l'intérieur
alors je vais vous proposer quelque
chose c'est d'aller vous cacher oui
c'est vrai et ensuite on va vous trouver
et on jugera
on va me trouver aussi difficilement que
vous nous avez jugé luc engines bordeaux
bon les gars on y va vous avez vous
cacher on peut faire un truc défait de
film d'action pas quand j'allume salon
c'est un sabre laser qui fait un trou et
qui fait une innovation et repartir rien
à rajouter une semaine de montage tu
veux on paye cet effet allez-y passé
régis passé vous allez voir je te
remercie mes valeurs allegro est à toi
tu prend les escaliers étaient trop
grands
[Musique]
bon mec en face ils sont très forts
sachez que je suis déjà classé terrible
il faut qu'on retrouve la puissance ils
vont utiliser des comédiens genre des
morceaux de décors faits sur mesure
là on part sur notre première cachette
première cachette je peux l'un des
volets 44 15 15 le florilège de boîtes
aux lettres on l'appelle comme ça ils
sont capables de folie mais c'est un
monde fou on s'est bien amusé en bas là
je veux dire que l'ambiance elle va
changer séchons mais regarde le détail
des stop pub des noms pareils
j'aime beaucoup celle là elle est bien à
vivre cette peur legacy face devant sans
rien dire c'est la folie quel est ce que
je pense qu'il faut que je puisse tisser
une demi heure mais que vous êtes mal je
fais gaffe qui ne brille pas vraiment
dire si je vais au nouveau paradis ou là
ils sont bien devant nous oh la la il ya
un truc qui peut nous aider c'est le
temps vu on va attendre avant de les
chercher plus leurs cachettes elle est
longue à mettre en place
il faut aussi penser à l'évidence on
sait qu'ils sont techniques ils peuvent
nous avoir un truc évident en fait ouais
claustro
max line m'appelle max i'm appel à l'eau
on est caché oui il m'arrive les gars
c'est à quel serait son vote
on a comme elle en a vingt minutes c'est
ça c'est parti faisait les gros ils sont
verts le picard un mariage pourquoi le
ce camion pourquoi il ya autant de gens
qui nous regardent de partout y'a un mec
la loi sapin qui nous regardent
ah non il fume une clope juste
[Musique]
ils sont quelque part ici mec
on est pile sur fléau après si je parle
carrément tang vous ne nous entendez la
regarde tout autour de toi c'est sûr ils
sont dans un truc camoufler sur non mais
mais qu'ils peuvent pas s'être déguisé
en panneaux on est en train de devenir
fou la ministre qu'est-ce qu'ils ont bon
les mecs c'est un délai le temps c'est
quoi cette île sont sous nos yeux on va
péter un câble pour son refus ils sont
en carton cherche des gens cachés plein
derrière
ok vous n'êtes pas si ce taux dans un
bâtiment c'est une salle sur que c'est
pas des tricheurs et sont sous nos yeux
[ __ ] là et nous voilà il tape la barre
de leur vie en ce moment même je
comprends pas mince mais moi non plus en
fait tout le monde a des regards
complices
mais qui sont transformés en toutes
boîtes aux lettres
si je mets deux jours sans sait jamais
d'où ça vient de moi ton la taxe est
sûre c'est ça s'est fait tout
personne minutes de l'apport lé gard où
elle s'était du génie heureusement je
sais que les minettes n'est jaloux et
violent s'est jamais dehors on veut
sortir jeta dans la voiture je me suis
dit c'est bon je les connais ils sont
fourbes et veulent avoir un petit
plaisir c'est celui de nous voir entre
auxerre bon bah c'est des petits fours
la mairie
bravo pour cette magnifique et les gars
c'est à nous deuxièmes gachettes vous
conclure que la première bonne chance à
lui
[Musique]
ces moments celle là c'est un tel
plaisir je suis ton excité je suis hyper
excité nous n'avons pas bougé depuis
quand on est devant la boîte aux notes
regardez ici on a soupçonné qui se
battent dans la ville il a emménagé
récemment dans une belle maison dans
cette belle maison on a placé 30
mannequin j'adore vous faire part des
draps mais nous comme on doit se cacher
en extérieur on va se mettre sous un
buisson dans son jardin et ça se
confirme au mans demain une fois que
total juste pour que le cerveau je
précise quand même que la femme de david
et complices et que c'est grâce à elle
qu'on peut avoir la meilleure cachette
de l'histoire donc un début de match
fait du gavet la confiance pas bon ok on
vient d'arriver chez david il ya plein
de mannequin david a emménagé dans cette
maison il ya une semaine il connaît pas
par coeur tous ouais donc on a notre
chance on a le moyen de le brain
le stress est grand les sensations dans
les jambes qui reviennent et tous les
amis le plan est simple on doit se
cacher d'ici là et regardez on a plein
d'accessoires pour être couvert ces
prêts si vous regardez bien la direction
comprend regarde cette direction ok on a
emmené en possession pourquoi ils sont
là juste si près de chez nous on est au
top
vas-y recouvrer non recouvrées nous
frappe c'est ainsi qu'elle m'a posé
quelques questions sur le tournage olala
remake c'est incroyable s'il tourne
c'est ma rue il n'y a pas de discussion
à droite c'est un canton à droite se
fout des amis si vous saviez comment ils
vont avoir la rage mais là c'est pas
trop
j'appelle qualité ayasse cozic appel à
l'eau on est caché une caméra c'est faux
c'est fini ta femme non mais toi qu'est
ce que c'est que ça et toi qu'est ce que
c'est que ça c'est une mise aux plus
tard et qu'est ce que c'est que ça ils
font fort lesquels viennent d'arriver on
a entendu la porte claquée au quai
parole à eduardo lui partout où allait
m'annoncer bon allez allez faut être
agréé en mai chez toi notre actif en
[ __ ] l'angoissé pas tant ils sont pas
cachés derrière ça tu verras tu te fous
de moi mais je l'aï même pas vu
débarquer steve on regarde vie est rude
regard non ils nous foutent le sommes je
suis bloqué [ __ ] je suis bloqué je
suis bloqué va la voir ensemble mes
berton non écoute moi il m'écoute pas
c'est fou bon ben moi je vais là où je
veux être avec toi liste les mieux la
trouve belle écoute la phrase on pense à
un fossé fournir d'être ensemble mais
bâtard qu'est ce tu peux te la foule a
du coup
[Musique]
le mec est plus de moi c'est mon frère
il engueule mekhloufi sont même pas
check et bien je sais pas j'avais vu ce
que tu veux mais coupe tu connais bien
ta maison tu connais bien la maison à
[ __ ] mais maintenant ça fera un nom
mais sont là je me sens encore chef de
gamin je les entend se rapprocher d'une
cachette à l'ancienne c'est à l'ancienne
je suis très nul à observer de près la
vie de tournée où toi j'ai tout chèque
est tous là où il n'y a rien on est
marseillais 12 mois avec ma maison en 12
mois hors épargne au plus tôt mais je
suis tout l'air d'un coup ça
[Musique]
aucun de sa grande mais c'est parfait
c'est un cargo mais ça me regarde ce que
j'ai vu là
[Musique]
à quel malade se laisse se laisse vous
lui
vous savez quoi vente aux enchères le
paquebot pardon on veut pas trop flouté
bien lancée
on a regardé mieux la prendre la route
et bien il vaut mieux car en fait l on
avait mis aulas ou chez moi je vais pas
chaque fois avec ce qui s'est passé ici
j'aimerais revenir sur ça dans un élan
de rage raphaël retourne le mobilier
j'en ai marre sérieux parce que tu sais
pas c'est qu'il ya un coussin qui allait
se poser sur le pied de nez en ce moment
là précisément ces m'a dit je suis mon
[ __ ] de sa grand père comme je range
de par son souhait j'ai trouvé les gars
là bravo bravo la grogne
[Musique]
il est temps de vous dévoiler notre
deuxième cachette
ça fait des mois qu'on la conserve ça y
est c'est beaucoup d'émotions depuis ce
matin ces deux personnes film
facticement
connais tu regardes re va simplement
être cachés en eux voilà moi je pense
qu'il peut y avoir du comédien ouais
ouais c'est sûr mais je les vois pas
faire un truc sans comédiens ça c'est
quoi ça
on
ouais on a le ventre plein et fatigué on
va les trouver
allez on les appelle c'est parti on est
cachée hockey des jo mais qu on est en
face de matignon quel culot izon [ __ ]
ils sont dans un parc
ils doivent être super bien dès qu'ils
exactement j'aille à débattre non mais
il faut qu'on arrête d'être attirés par
les poubelles c'est pas normal
[Musique]
ou bien on fait en tout cas on analyse
juste m'a dit vas-y c'est d'accord
pourquoi ces tessinois c'était assez bon
quand même
oui les gars je suis désolé mais on est
chronométré on va trouver même à creil
carlito la suite de cache-cache vous
avez des indices ou comment faire qu'est
ce qu'ils sont nous nous a dit qu'on
faisait le 2 et tu sais très bien que tu
étais pas dedans et en plus il savait
aussi qu'on pouvait pas jouer la
surprise est venue avait dit allez les
gars venez nous aider réelle elle est
vraie il y aurait pu avoir un texto
après
j'aime bien les inner ses rangs les
étapes dans le tas d'or dans sa tendance
à la justice résumé me dont le seul s'il
est là dessus il va être blessé il est
pas là et a pris des risques mais je
gardais jusqu'à combien de personnes
avec je sais que les ventes leurs
cachettes elle est nulle
sinon il enverrait pas autant leur nom
est robert n'a pas on attend et on nous
dit nous valons de ce qu'on sait faire
mais on n'est pas allé là bas on est
allé là-bas 0 il doit nous rester genre
15 minutes là ce qui est mon frère c'est
mon frère va si bien des gelées la
caisse que la guerre fait lâcher nos
lucas on a bien regardé volé en éclats
concentre toi c'est évident c'est sous
mozilla c'est sous les évidences et sous
nos yeux c'est pas de la ville de calais
aux émois en plus sur la mer mais ça
serait pas david le lien
[Musique]
j'aurais vraiment aimé que ça se passe
on aurait aimé que ça se passe comme ça
un générique se régaler les spectateurs
ne comprennent pas les noms je vais leur
dire mais en gros c'était un échec
cuisant
on rembobine à peu en arrière voilà ce
qui s'est vraiment passé auquel a dû aux
mecs julien ont fait un tour on en a les
yeux des masses étaient d'accord les
gars je suis désolé mais on est
chronométré on va trouver la faille
qu'arbitre mon sens nous allez les gars
viennent nous aider en vrai il y aurait
pu avoir un texto eh bien les inertes et
qu'on les ignore ou métro due soit en
évidence ils sont évidents c'est un
attentat au regard des quatre heures
attention il ya 24 heures cachées ya toi
c'était sur comment je me mets moi c'est
pas grave rires il ya deux parties c'est
pas grave on croyait avec les équipes
depuis tellement de temps que vous avez
passé depuis le début de la journée il
ya deux mecs qui card pour rien mais tu
me dis qu'avec du monde et avait déjà
prévu pour faire quoi j'étais tout ça
tout a capoté le bien sûr
là
mais si les hommes s'amusent tout ça
mais on est trop froid en fait comme un
gant au fait on sait enfin je sais pas
quoi vous dire à part on est trop fort
les amis je suis désolé que votre
appétit garate mais d'un autre côté je
vais être très honnête avec vous quel
soulagement pour seb et moi d'avoir
trouvé sa deuxième quart
c'était une idée géniale c'est horrible
que tu me rassures tout cas monsieur la
chose est sûre pas gagné on est des
craintes les gars a noté crack en
commentaire suivant départ
[Musique]
nous nous dirigeons car notre troisième
cas chez lui nous allons être dans un
faux déménagement s'il ne trouve pas ça
va leur mettre une pression sur les prix
qu'ils ont l'ascendant psychologique
c'est un moment difficile mais on doit
penser à michael jordan
faute de dentaire même quand ils
perdaient un quart temps et qui seraient
charriés il arrivait bien justement en
fait c'était une motivation
supplémentaire pour gagner
messieurs dames nous sommes sur les
lieux du détachement
certes il est très drôle on va être tout
au fond caché dans deux grands cartons
il va y avoir trois faux déménageur qui
vont essayer dé stopper basile adios n
en est qu on se voit ses traces de pas
la réserve et regarder comment c'est
génial bien des trous dans le truc pour
voir le carton de m
oui la géoloc les amis nous emmène place
d'italie au débat bonne chance à tous
bonne chance à mon âge ou à tan tan tan
tan s'appelle à aulas ils sont déjà
cuites à l'eau on est gay
[Musique]
bon ok on regarde la géoloc il vise qu à
la map la petite halle à les séduire on
passe au milieu on aura plus de chance
il se passe un truc
ça va la femme je sais pas si c'est pas
prévu ça pour vous est prévu sais pas si
c'est pas trop ça me stresse cette vidéo
ou faut garder en tête savoir la géoloc
là bas
[Musique]
on est dessus là là ok pour une
stratégie et des trucs là il ya le
centre déménagement a fait ménagement
des médailles où il ya un truc
déménagement après la terre enfin qu'on
est bien oreiller qui est tout ça ça me
parle ça
bonjour je vous avais bien ça se passe
bien je suis en fait on cherche des gens
qui sont cachés dans paris mais ça se
trouve ils sont cachés la wii et un
caméraman noir et non mais bien sûr
aussi subtile pas d'accord non mais il
filme pas mais même moi tu fais pas il
te demande de bois film est une autre
affaire
badaroux alors il joue très long c'est
dur compliqué c'est la comédie la
compagnie parler hors caméras en tout
cas ok il faut lui demander très très
gentiment et filmé par y aller vers la
face caméra pas de canard à nous acteurs
là ils ont gardé leur chambre basse et
que enchères on est dans une vidéo
youtube et b ont fait un cache cache
mais a trouvé son cachet maintenant ok
mais moi j'ai les noms malheureuse mais
le problème c'est qu'ils auraient pu
prendre un comédien qui joue c'est ça le
prend une course à conditions que j'ai
l'air d'être un comédien à 21h hier le
couvre feu
jcg soir
ménard vit présentement est ce que c'est
moi je te parle très gentiment geder on
peut pas regarder ça et vite mais ne
peut pas regarder trop fort de la
pression que ça fout ça se faisait une
grosse sensation c'est une [ __ ] de
feintes
ah ça y est ça me ferait face à un truc
horrible sa toiture tête à leur place
quand tu pars à clarac c'est un des
pires moments de ma vie on est en train
de perdre un temps pas possible ça se
trouve c'est parait que veux tu regardes
pas rentrer moi je vais pas forcer 6 ans
maintenant nous a dit vous pouvez pas
rentrer genre elle seule en fait il faut
qu'ils sens c'est quoi les gars s'il
commence à s'effriter vous intervenez il
est hyper chaud soyez prêt juste je vais
fermer la porte si tu y vas donc c'est
pas fou mais ils vont s'énerver de quoi
les temps pour guérir ou en leur
demandant leur demande un peu de cas et
je suis désolé pour qu'on avance dans le
camion on va juste jeter un oeil ça
prend deux secondes on fait rien juste
on s'y attendait c'est pas contre vous
il n'y a rien de méchant regarder je met
les mains dans le dos de caméras
d'arrêter suis dégoûté at on idée car
pour me fait une fois je te rendrai
touches séparées trois déménagements
tifo mais là des cartons vides
t'inquiète pas que c'est pas ça et ils
sont là
la chaleur la chaleur kelman roussillon
gagné c'était superbe
sa vie c'était un monstre mais c'est
grâce à rapporter amour élevées des
rouges
mais m mais comment on a tous suivi de
l'intérieur toi je te fais un canal est
injoignable
n'at il a été incroyable je voulais plus
sortir j'avais peur je tue c'est le seul
truc qui m'a remis dedans à chaque fois
quand on est arrivé vous vous regardiez
pas alors tout où on nous regarde et il
y avait les mains dans le dos que canal
avait rassuré à la sécu si la demande
est là c'est qu'il est
moi je suis né dans la pauvreté ont
déroché aller tous ensemble c'est tous
les quinze jours
je suis fier de vous
[Musique]
c'est l'enjeu lacets égalité ou victoire
de leur part c'est ça qui se passe c'est
le temps de vous dire la dernière
cachette vazaha caissettes a été inspiré
par cette zone de mon meilleur ami
qu'elle veut ce qui pourrait aisément
ressemble à une pastèque
lorsque c'est bien maquillée c'est leur
master ils vont être bien cachés vers
une mise en scène la gp11
nous avons simplement nous glisser dans
les fruits de ce primeur nous allons
simuler des pastèques et les fraises
ils sont dans une rue comme nous avec le
déménagement pareil sauf qu'il fait nuit
donc si c'est un élément du décor là si
on gagne là dessus je suis plus heureux
des hommes
ils vont jamais trouvé c'est un mix de
bon décor de bon camouflage dans des
objets du quotidien et comme les hauts
murs est farfelu mac fraises et post &
co je suis bien je fais un petit dodo si
je suis confiant n'oubliez pas aussi le
truc de sens un mardi à 19h56 il ya des
trucs qui se font
j'aimerais que je ne vois une heures du
couvre-feu
une pastèque ou melon rideau revoir tout
on arrive bientôt sur les lieux le
stress mec c'est ok les amis je vais
passer un coup de plus ils m'appellent
m'appelle m appelle au mercy mais c'est
royal
alors on prend notre temps on est
insolent pour le dernier round
comprendre que le plus gros est lancé ok
on court pas on laisse le temps au
cadran
comment allez-vous soit bien non la
position elle est là bas je les entends
une laverie nettement faire on va voir
ce qui se passe orioli sur virbac de
frais de ce qu'on croyait
ah ouais on n'osera jamais
on
via des passagers
je n'ai pas vu quand ils sont par là
mais j'imagine ils ont fait un faux
monument
et c'est intéressant la fontaine
c'est vrai c'est vrai moi je rassurais
sont pas tombés tout de suite c'est
est-ce qu'ils seraient pas déguiser
encore une fois
ils n'ont pas construit une fausse
terrasson autres cas là qu'on n'entend
vraie vie on se concentre son casque et
par effet qu un tonton cet écran est
faux il y avait une pub pour la perte de
cheveux
je trouve pas du tout relève un peu la
tête voire un peu de 12 minutes
maintenant c'est fou c'est un homme aux
yeux c'est son nom officiel que son mec
c'est dur là ne leur vois rien en fait
et puis même de nuit là c'est très très
dur
mexes et la laverie c'est un truc du
genre
[Musique]
c'est ici c'est sûr et nous voient ils
sont morts de rire maintenant mais ses
filles a rien ici là rien c'est ça quand
tu rentres que dans notre sens est rien
je deviens fou mec là fond de la mer
gros tu fais taper dans tout ce que j'ai
à vous il n'y a rien c'est des vrais
machine
le seul qui peut être faussée ça et ils
ont ajouté derrière mais il est
électronique annonce officiellement le
sablier dans les cinq dernières minutes
n'y serai là
non mais qui je crois qu'on perd du
temps si la vie de ma mère on va pas
trouver la bomba ont valu aux mecs là je
sais pas mais je pense quoi c'est pas un
mec
cherche des personnes cachées pour une
vidéo youtube non vous n'êtes pas
comédien ya un escalier qui descend là
il ya un escalier je peux descendre pas
je vais voir chez moi je crois et toute
la vie de ma mère je vais boire
non c'est pas là c'est pas la mecque je
t'aime tu sais on alloue sur ça ouais
les gars vous avez pas une petite faim
si bas on est entouré de deux choses
qu'on peut manger sinon si on souhaite
je pense qu'ils ont besoin
il envoie un courrier me station il est
hélas ouvre les bâtards une pastèque par
une vaste façade regard sur son crâne
aux attendes c'est quoi ça c'est tombé
avec toi c'est fou mais petit mois sa
vidéo dessus c'est spectaculaire
les gars c'est bien joué nos réflexes
liés aux qu'ovide font qu'on n'aurait
jamais osé toucher le poteau
attendez attendez à ce que vous et moi
aujourd'hui elle est géniale d'accord
envers cette idée c'était un grand bravo
les gars c'est une victoire méritée ya
là on peut poursuivre cet été sont pour
toute l'équipe
mégalo jamais une calvitie net et si
bien utiliser ses mains de dieu et c'est
quoi moi je suis un rageux sa part d'un
ami où je perds et j'en écris 1 h 8
seulement 4 ans et et non c'était
incroyable son premier mois de garde ça
jusqu'à demain soir s'est pas passé
comme si tout va comme gentil moi je
veux dire à mes petites filles à papa
stack les gars bravo est incroyable je
suis tellement content victoire 3-2
bravo à toute l'équipe
merci à rhinochill évidemment pas me
dire de chennai a pas tous cas tort il
aussi acheter leurs produits et tout de
suite pas pastèque
[Musique]